je vous le dis c'est fini puisqu'on en
fait on nous nous envoyons pas d'invités
on s'est rendu compte qu'on n'en avait
pas besoin
parce que l'émission n'a jamais aussi
bien marché ça marche très fort pour
nous alors que leurs émissions sont en
difficulté donc je vous le dis voilà on
vous aime et non mais bon voilà je vous
le dis on n'a rien contre vous on veut
pas mais eksi ya des invités de thé des
gens doutaient pas qu'ils veulent venir
en ami comme ça tu as vraiment en ami et
en publie sont les bienvenus poignard et
les mettront pas longtemps voilà mais
s'ils veulent venir en danois ya pas de
problème et sinon bien sûr il y voit là
ils auraient peur tellement d'autres
choses à faire
elle s'est vidée la route et le bouquet
entendu c'est sa rue et là on vient de
me dire de toutes les façons avec doc
gynéco qui rend non mais qu'est-ce qu'il
a eu un frère il a parlé il a mangé de
la mairie
[Applaudissements]
bon les séries